joining us now from Capitol Hill Peter
Doocy outside Senator Marco Rubio's
office with the senator who hasn't
spoken out here yet Peter we are inside
senator Rubio's office senator Rubio
this happened in your state who have you
been talking to and what have you been
hearing well we've talked to the local
authorities were in charge of this
investigation the sheriff's office
obviously the first responders there and
the Superintendent of Schools itself a
terrible situation it's going to be a
pretty dramatic casualty number a lot of
the authorities to make that
announcement my understanding is some of
the next-of-kin families have not yet
been notified and I also hope people
will reserve judgment on I've seen a lot
of already people on television talking
about why this happened the facts of
this case are important and as if more
details become available we'll have a
deeper conversation about why these
things are happening but it's a so one
that's a day you pray whenever happened
as has happened and this is a situation
where unlike school shootings 10 20
years ago there are a lot of pictures
and videos coming from inside the school
is there anything that you have seen so
far today that is stuck with you
particularly well obviously we had some
of the students that were inside or
using social media to document the
moment by moment there is one image
unfortunately it's out there in the
public
of someone that was injured nope no face
or identifying features but perhaps
enough for a loved one to see you then
and then think that that might be one of
their their loved ones who have been
impacted by this but there's a terrible
situation and that's amazing the amount
of carnage that one individual could
carry out in such a short period of time
if it's well orchestrated and planned
and as I said I maintenance as the it's
still an active scene by the way I mean
the authorities are still working
through the school to see what else is
there and but I think we'll learn more
in the next 12 hours that will shed a
little bit more light as to something
how something like this can happen and
what kind of updates are you getting doo
doo does the FBI call you does the
governor call you while the governor's
travel down there he was out of the
state and we've spoken to local
authorities but one things we have to
understand this they're just working
their way through the building right now
so I see a lot of people out there on
television speculating about this I
think that's important for it to wait
for the facts there may be more about
this in terms of what they find once
they get inside the building and then
the numbers may change they're still
working through the villain there's a
protocol they have to follow to ensure
that there has been explosives I'm not
saying that there is I'm just saying the
protocol that they follow so it's still
an active scene and and not to mention
evidence they have to gather I mean this
is an individual who's gonna be
prosecuted for this and this is a school
shooting where the individual suspected
of carrying it out escaped survived he
was taken to a hospital he is in custody
what should happen in this person well
obviously he's gonna be charged of the
crime but most importantly for law
enforcement in the short term is they'll
want to know if anyone else was involved
and whether there's any existing
dangerous sometimes these things become
complex there might have been an
incident that happened beforehand you
may learn that others have been hurt in
the process or that there's
behind that could be harmful to people
so there's a lot that goes into this
this I know people often use I'm not
saying you but just in general if they
need to report in real time but there's
a protocol law enforcement follows the
first is to prevent any further injury
and the next is to gather evidence
because this guy's going to trial there
needs to be evidence presented in order
to gain a conviction based on what
you've seen from the response I know
that this just happened a few hours ago
but there are probably a lot of students
and their families watching they won't
have school for the next few days but
but should they feel safe going back
well as I said I mean this is we're
gonna learn more about the facts of this
case over the next few hours and as the
public becomes aware of them it'll shine
light on it and the be a lot of
questions asked but in the interim I
would say that for those who have not
been harmed or obviously grateful and
happy that that's the case for those who
have an impact that are even by the
students that may not have been
physically harmed but have had to go
through this experience you know we just
want to ensure that they have all the
resources available our school district
down there and Broward is a phenomenal
district they're well very well
organized
they're already mobilizing all the sorts
of counseling efforts done everyone
involved in this is going to need this
is not the kind of thing that you expect
when you send when your kids go away to
school and it's not something that you
know people easily confront it's a
difficult thing they thought through the
injuries here are deeper than just a
physical ones but our immediate thoughts
are were those who have lost a loved one
and perhaps have not have even been
notified some of your colleagues in the
Senate here from Washington DC had
already been trying to make this about
policy and about gun control is this the
appropriate time to be doing that oh
it's not only because people don't they
don't know how this happened let me have
it who this person is what motivated
them how did they get ahold of the
weapon that they use for this attack I
think it's important to know all of that
before you jump to conclusions that
there's some law that we could have
passed that could have prevented it and
there may be but shouldn't we at least
know the facts and so I I think that you
can always have that debate but if
you're gonna have the debate about this
particular incident
should know the facts that incident
before you run out and prescribe some
law that you claim could have prevented
it I've seen a lot of that on television
and maybe there is a law that could have
prevented this instance but we don't
know that and neither do they do you
have any plans to go back to Florida
sooner than originally yeah I mean
obviously we have a vote scheduled here
on an important topic on immigration and
so we'll have to evaluate how it is that
we can get there and what you know what
would be appropriate in terms of the
setting there in place but that I'm sure
that you know will be there at some
point here soon and as I said it's still
a developing situation all right about
that far so right all right Senator
Marco Rubio from Florida
Brett Peter Thank You senator thank you
for the time